et comment ça va bien je viens vous
parler aujourd'hui d'un smartphone dont
j'aurais dû vous parlait il ya déjà un
petit moment mais à cause de la cuvée du
fait que j'étais sur la route avec
amazon je voulais déjà dit j'ai
malheureusement pas eu le temps de vous
en parler plus tôt mais apparement
boxing on va donc tout de suite corrigé
le tir on va se faire le test de ce
smartphone là c'est le one + 8 et sais
pas si vous le savez wen plus mais
toujours fer de lance en termes
d'innovation a fait beaucoup évoluer ses
gammes vont trouver tous les ans un
produit phare a ensuite le produit phare
avec le thé à côté d'autres notamment
ici le one + 8 et il ya eu les modèles
professionnels l'année dernière ça l'est
encore une nouvelle gamme qui arrivent
et qui est la gamme normes qui s'étend
de plus en plus et où en plus s'est
construit sur une image de flagship qui
leur proposait les dernières innovations
ce qui se fait de mieux à tarifs
beaucoup plus bas autant l'année
dernière où une puce sorti en août +7
teheran - de +7 tpr au autant cette
année ils ont fait le choix de sortir
uniquement
est-ce que tu as très bien en vain de +8
et donc ici pas de modèle professionnel
on l'a donc un modèle qui se situe un
peu à mi chemin entre le one + 8 et le
one + 8 pro et surtout l'équation qui
est très compliqué c'est qu'aujourd'hui
dans ce segment de prix 599 euros sur
une config 8 gigas de ram 128 go de
stockage ou 12 igad ram 256 go de
stockage à 699 euros
bêtise soit vérifiée quand même est pas
malin et bien la problématique c'est
qu'il ya beaucoup de monde son marché ça
devient de plus en plus compliqué pour
un constructeur de tirer son épingle du
jeu est de réussir à convaincre
on va râler donc de telle manière est ce
que moins de plus chaque chat vous
convaincre qu'est-ce qu'il vous propose
comme innovation est ce qu ils le font
bien est-ce que ce point de +8 et est
intéressant ou alors pas du tout mais
avant d'aller plus loin dans cette vidéo
je t'invite à venir cliquer sur le petit
bouton rouge et beaucoup de rouge ici
aujourd'hui cliquez sur le bouton rouge
pour venir vous abonner parce qu'on
parle de teck je vous parle bien
évidemment de vous de votre vie
numérique des bons usages je teste des
smartphones notamment comme le web + 8 t
ici je vous parle d'eux tech
en règle générale donc vous invite à
venir cliquer sur le petit bouton rouge
pour tout savoir de l'actuelle activer
la cloche comme ça vous serez notifié
dès qu une prochaine vidéo arrivera ça
c'est bien ça ça les trucs que j'aime le
plus au smart phone c'est son blog de
charge
ça pourrait être bizarre de se dire
je kiffe un lob de charge mais je le
kiffe parce que ça c'est un bloc de
charge de 65 watts qui vous permet de le
recharger en à peine 15 minutes de
charge de gagner une journée d'autonomie
ça c'est une des nouveautés chez one
plus dans cette deuxième partie de
l'année cela voir une recharge
extrêmement rapide
avant on avait déjà de la 24e but est
d'aller rapidement de recharger
rapidement mêlant va beaucoup plus loin
avec ce bloc de jargeau 65 watts et je
vous dis en très peu de temps vous
gagnez une journée d'autonomie donc ça
c'est quand même un côté qui est très
rassurant ça vous élimine de votre tête
la question de hamas est ce que j'ai à
cette batterie est ce que je vais
manquer est ce que juste d'être à court
alors bien évidemment si vous retrouvez
dans un transport en commun et que vous
n'avez pas de prise à côté de vous vous
risquez d'être bloqués mais si vous
retrouvez au bureau chez vous avant de
partir que vous avez 10 minutes devant
vous dix minutes un quart d'heure et
bien pour charger très rapidement et ça
c'est très rassurant
ça c'est le point positif maintenant il
ya toutes vos questions un peu dubitatif
c'est que avec le one + sud pro en début
d'année la charge sans fil a fait son
arrivée chez one plus passant de + 8 mai
sur notre bus fils trop donc je
m'attendais ce que sur un modèle tu es
un modèle demi génération en fin d'année
on est également de la recharge sans fil
ce qui ici n'est absolument pas le cas
ce qui fait que j'ai un smartphone qui
est haut de gamme clairement mais je ne
peux pas bénéficié d'une des dernières
technologies de wang plus et ça ça reste
malgré tout un peu frustrant parce
qu'une fois de plus ce smartphone il
faut pas le comparer forcément aux
autres modèles de one plus mais le
comparer à la concurrence dans le même
segment de prix et dans le même segment
de prix vous avez beaucoup de
smartphones qui se recharge sans fil
faut savoir qu'ici vous avez une grosse
batterie de 4500 millions opéra en fait
ce sont deux batteries différentes qui
sont à l'intérieur aux smartphones et
qui permet de le recharger plus
rapidement le truc est pratique c'est
que si vous utilisez un autre chargeur
rapide vous et pouvoir charger ici en 27
watts maximum et que si vous utilisez
votre blog de charges sur un ordinateur
sur une console sur ce que vous voulez
et bien vous allez pouvoir recharger en
45 watts le deuxième point que j'aime
beaucoup dans ce smartphone c'est son
écran il est extrêmement bien maîtrisé
on a ici un écran fluide à molette un
écran avec un taux de rafraîchissement
de 120 hertz alors d'envoi de plus suite
vous aviez un écran 24 au graphisme en
de 90 heures
ici on ne regrette en 120 hertz et 46 55
pouces résolution full hd + ratio vingt
neuvième hdr 10 plus un écran qui est
très lumineux un verre corning gorilla
glass pour moi l'expérience est vraiment
très très bonne pour tout votre contenu
multimédia one + maîtrise sa dalle que
ce soit pour l'expérience de visionnage
séries philes vous allez vraiment
quelque chose qui marche extrêmement
la partie audio est plutôt pas mal
haut-parleurs stéréo bon c'est pas un
truc est complètement dingos parce qu'on
s'habitue à avoir ce genre de système et
ça marche bien c'est très très bien sûr
tout qui est intéressant aussi c'est con
hein ça fait quand même puissant qui ne
va pas venir saturent à pleine puissance
votre haut parleurs principal se trouve
là on va utiliser le haut parleur ici
qu'on va utiliser pour nos appels
téléphoniques sur le dessus qui
fonctionnera très très bien bonne
expérience multimédia fait une série
gaming ça marche mais puisqu'on parle de
guémy c'est un des points forts de one
plus c'est la performance sont toujours
axé leurs smartphones performants
beaucoup de performances on a ici un des
derniers soc de qualcomm
c'est le syndrome 865 on a soit 8 soit
12 giga de ram
la techno c'est d'la et pdr 4x pour le
stockage on est en ef s 3.0 qui est une
des dernières technologies en lecture et
en écriture donc pour tous vos usages ça
ira bien et même pour le gaming vous
allez voir un smartphone qui va être
très performant qui va très bien
répondre à toutes vos sollicitations le
troisième point qui est pour moi
vraiment très très bon chemin de plus
c'est la partie os
ici vous avez oxygène os qui est basé
sur un android 11 c'est toujours très
bien maîtrisée de la part de one plus
très complet les options sont très
nombreuses des effets de couleurs vives
si vous le souhaitez vous pouvez aller
loin en termes de personnalisation c'est
une des meilleures expériences qu'on va
retrouver ici avec moi nous y de samsung
avec me wade est aussi monté aux
qualités de xiaomi si vous voulez une
expérience logiciel claire et lisible là
dessus vous avez vraiment ce qu'il faut
je crains pas le design sans pour autant
retrouver révolutionnaire one + change
et vous des portes son blog photos ici
sur le côté c'est quelque chose qu'on
trouve beaucoup cette année
ce bloc de photos déplacer son côté on
reste dans les standards qu'on peut
retrouver à peu près partout on perd un
peu de l'identité douane plus mais
malgré tout ça reste très efficace
par contre ce qui est très très bien
maîtrisé c'est qu'ici votre dos eh bien
il prend vraiment pas les traces de
doigts ça évite les salissures donc ça
c'est vraiment un bon point on va aller
encore plus loin en parlant de la photo
je vous ai déjà expliqué lors dun boxing
vous avez ici un ultra grand angle en
dessous un grand-angle de la macro et un
capteur monochrome et double flash led
c'est intéressant grand angle ultra
grand-angle ok mais capteurs monochrome
bon ok ça peut avoir un sens je suis
d'accord avec ça mais le capteur de
maquereaux ici non non non au moins de
plus vous avez déjà fait beaucoup mieux
en intégrant de la macro sur votre
capteur ultra grand-angle
grand petit motors ça c'était vachement
pertinent est vachement intéressant ce
qui fait qu'on avait un bien meilleur
capteur au niveau de l' ultra
grand-angle qui servait à la macro grâce
à ce petit moteur tandis que là on a un
5 mégapixels alors ok on a plus de 2
mégapixels que dans le one + 8 ou
n'avait que 2 mégapixels en accro mais
non pour moi c'est pas la combinaison
gagnante moi ce que j'attends d'un
smartphone à 600 euros ou à 700 euros
c'est d'avoir grand angle ultra grand
angle au téléobjectif triptyque de base
ont commencé photo par la caméra de
celle fille voilà on continue des photos
vous des prix dans l'avion je pense que
vous vous en douterez le capteur
principal fracas fait pas beaucoup de
lumière mais ça fera halte à l'ultra
grand temps leurs accus perdu bruins
allez voir c'est pas extraordinaire on
en reparle un petit peu plus loin on
vient nous mais en x de hockey le x 10
ont doublé dès que vous avez plus de
lumière sa faune sera tout de suite
beaucoup mieux c'est normal c'est comme
ça que fonctionne la faute au capteur
principal savall ultra-grand-angle faut
vraiment qu'ils beaucoup de lumière
parce que on perd quand même en
précision je vous remet on sent un peu
plus loin le x 2 on peut réussir à faire
quelque chose et le x 10 une faute plus
on oublie la macro une fois de plus je
dis non c'est un grand nom un très grand
nom je l'avais net sur mon écran quand
je les prises l ag du bruit ça lisse et
pas vous regarder franchement ça donne
envie ça ça vous donne envie
ces lycées le traitement logiciel il est
pas beau vraiment vraiment vraiment ça
pour moi c'est à proscrire par contre
quatre principales marche très bien
on n'est pas particulièrement saturé là
où d'autres constructeurs font ce choix
de un peu plus venir saturé ce registre
naturel pour moi le rendu là dessus
assez qualitatif letra grand tang est
pas génial hein on perd un peu on a du
bruit sur les côtés la voyez ça vient
glisser en une espèce de bruitages x 2
une fois de plus se fasse par le capteur
principal dont bon ça va c'est pas
horrible et le x 10 une fois de plus via
lycée vraiment il faut lobby la photo de
nuit va être bonne sur le capteur
principal ou s'en serait douté parce que
dès qu'on passe sur l' ultra grand-angle
n'a pas le choix dit lisa sion c'est
beaucoup moins bon la gestion des
lumières est beaucoup moins bonne des
principales c'est ok l' ultra grand
angle c'est pas beau capteur principal
c'est ok lui travaille en tant que c'est
pas beau qu'à toi principal c'est ok
ultra grand-angle
c'est pas beau et on a même ici de la
vidéo ultra stabiliser pour voir que
c'est ultra stabiliser pour moi c'est
pas génial il ya d'autres marques
proposent de l'utra stabilisé qui marche
très bien notamment au pot on vous
sur l'image pour moi foyer le rendu est
pas dingue ce one plus futés il a plein
de belles qualités réellement et
sincèrement son blog de charge 65 watts
très rapide ça c'est bien c'est
rassurant très bel écran bonne
expérience aux smartphones très
performants vous avez du dolby atmos
bluetooth 5 points à ptx à péter ex hd
elles des ac a assez il est très complet
mais je trouve que ce qui lui manque
dans cette gamme de prix une fois de
plus
599 et 699 eh bien c'est la photo on va
passer le mot en photo le résultat est
pas mal le résultat honnête mais il
manque un peu de personnalité à plus de
punch et là dessus et c'est ce que je
lui reprochais parce que vous allez
retrouver en face doc smartphones qui
sont très bons en photo a quasiment le
même prix et c'est un peu ce qui vient à
manquer sur ce smartphone là si vous
voulez un smartphone très performant à
600 euros il est très cool
la dalle est très bonne expérience
logiciel est très bonne mais il y manque
un petit quelque chose pour qu'on se
dise ah ouais lowen +8 et c'est vraiment
le smartphone a recommandé donc si vous
aimez one plus vous voulez une bonne
expérience logiciel vous voulez un
smartphone qui se recharge très
rapidement avec un écran très bien
calibrée ou un peu suite et si
maintenant vous voulez vraiment ce qui
se fait de mieux en photo dans cette
gamme de prix
c'est pas cela qui me faudra pas ce que
vous en pensez vous en bas en
commentaire honnêtement je les aime bien
j'aime beaucoup en plus
faisons une marque est hyper sexy qui
développe de plus en plus il s'ouvre de
nouveaux horizons il sort de ce qu'ils
avaient l'habitude de faire il le faut
également parce que le marché se
complexifier qu'il faut être présent
pour pas se faire manger la stratégie
intéressante donc on suivra ça de près
et on verra ce que nous propose ou un
peu plus l'année prochaine
un one + 9 où est-ce qu'ils vont passer
à une autre appellation white et aussi à
très bientôt des bisous monde beaucoup
d'amour ciao
[Musique]